this is a production of Cornell
University
it's really really nice to be back uh
here to Ithaca again
and just to see so many old friends uh
Rebecca Nelson I'm looking at you right
now uh a couple other folks in the back
of the room here too uh but also to make
new friends too uh and I just came from
a meeting with the students and I really
really enjoy that the students are
always kind of they uh they really
really
uh you know just get get you pumped up
again and excited for the future uh so
today my title is is advances and
Adventures in potato and sweet potato
breeding I've had to spend 25 years in
and so I kind of subtitled this is some
things I've learned over the course of
of 30 years of breeding in my two
favorite crops and when I am kind of
asked by
commodity groups or Growers you know oh
which crop is your favorite one I say I
love both potato and sweet potato and I
work 100 in both right I mean that's the
that's that's the standard thing you got
to say
um uh but what I what I thought I would
do today is just kind of share with you
some things that I I feel like I've
learned a little bit or that have have
an impression on me uh over the years uh
to a certain degree as I stand before
the Cornell plant breeding group I sort
of say to myself well you all know this
already all right but I'm going to kind
of apply it in my context in my two
crops and kind of give you some thoughts
but before I do that I think it's kind
of important for you to know what what
my mission is uh what our goals of of
our potato and sweet potato breeding
programs are and they're very very
simple all right we're a variety
development program
all right so that's that's our number
one mission is variety of development to
do that we conduct all types of genetic
and breeding studies and we incorporate
conventional you know specialty crop
industrial ornamental types in in my
sweet potato program pretty much the
same in potato and we're using
traditional and genomic based methods
we're using whatever tools we need to
get the job done so in certain cases
they're very rudimentary tools but in
other cases they're very very
sophisticated tools and I'll share with
you with that I really feel fortunate
and especially after coming to visit the
the uh The Graduate students is our role
as a land-grant university in training
and professional development of Tomorrow
scientists I think that's really
critical I think we all know that
standing here but we we take it
seriously and I I feel very fortunate to
kind of occupy a small space in that
area and then the third thing I guess is
provide opportunities
for Farmers today and tomorrow I've been
along around the job long enough now to
have known and continue to work with uh
kids of Growers that have grown up to
take over the farm
uh and I've seen them walking in the
fields when you know they were just yay
high and now they're managing the farm
themselves and that that's really a
special place to occupy too and to see
that transition is really important
um so that's our mission that's what we
do uh in in my programs and we take it
fairly seriously
um here are the things that I want to
talk with you about today and they're
they're basically
uh one two three four big pictures that
I wanted to visit with you about and
then share with you kind of how I see it
in my programs and how I've learned and
those those four topics are polyploidy
uh transdisciplinary Slash team based
research and the importance how
important has become I I'm very fond of
saying plant breeding is now a team
sport if you if you manage a large Plant
breeding program you better be a team
player or else you're going to get left
behind uh change is constant and if you
don't like change well you better get
used to it because it's going to come at
you from various ways I'm going to focus
on change in my breeding programs all
right and then the other thing here
which I am personally wrestling with I'm
not so sure that Ed wrestles with it too
much back there but I'm sure he does uh
Big Data and complex Analytics uh
they're here to stay uh and it it's uh
learning how to manage it learning how
to synthesize it learning how to make
sense out of it uh has been a constant
struggle for us uh it's really helped us
a lot but we still have a long way to go
so let me let me let me kind of pop into
the first one is
polyploid is an almost endless source of
variability
take these with somewhat of a grain of
salt all right it doesn't apply for
everything uh but this is my perspective
I start off my talks very often with
Growers uh when I'm talking about sweet
potato is uh this is a a field of sweet
potato nice vigorous Vine and if you get
lucky and you dig that crop you dig out
for a nice a nice crop of orange flesh
sweet potatoes in this case here
Walter this is Covington uh and we're
proud of that variety uh but I say to
you
that sweet potato is so much more uh
than what we know in the South as the
orange flesh of varieties they come in a
really really wide range of colors
shapes sizes flavors textures
Etc so we've got the orange flesh ones
you know up here we've got purple flesh
we actually just released two new purple
flushers which I think are going to be a
pretty big hit we have a lot of a lot of
interest in them we've got the staple
types which are predominantly grown in
across sub-Saharan Africa white fleshed
eye starch low sweetness varieties
really really important more and more
and this is where it comes from my
experience as a potato breeder in
potatoes you've got all kinds of value
added products
when I started my job as sweet potato
reader 25 years ago very few value-added
products all right but we're adding
value to sweet potato now in ways that
we have never done before uh probably
the one that you're most familiar with
certainly I'm most familiar with it
change my breeding program
uh is a sweet potato French fries
all right uh but they come in all kinds
of shapes and colors
I'll touch base on this in a little bit
this is uh ipamir batatis this is all
but taught us here right
these are ornamental sweet potatoes
they're bred using conventional means
conventional Crossing using Crossing
strategies we'd never use in table stock
sweet potatoes but to develop ornamental
sweet potatoes and I would argue that's
a consequence of polyploidy we've
Unleashed remarkable Gene combinations
and selection allows us to go in the
direction we want
so we'll talk about ornamentals a little
bit
uh we're making vodka I know that up
here is a is a big Distillery area too
uh this is Covington vodka I love the
little nometer down here the best yam
vodka on Earth
all right now sweet potatoes are not a
yam of course I'm not going to go into
that today but it that's great and I am
sure that there are people in this room
that are our dog lovers
and more and more you're going to see uh
pet foods that one of the primary
ingredients is going to be sweet
potatoes all right and you're going to
pay you know 50 bucks for a 25 pound or
a 40 pound bag uh for the sweet potato
enhanced dog food all right so there's a
lot of opportunity for our growers in
those areas uh and in the value-added
areas
the thing that really surprised me with
sweet potato and I'm really I'm really
pleased on this one and I'll touch base
on it briefly this is also sweet potato
right here
these are ornamental sweet potatoes
these two young fellows are me some time
ago and and a colleague of Mine by the
name of Ken pakota
uh Ken did his master's degree with Dr
Wanda Collins at NC State and sweet
potato breeding program uh he inherited
me and we've been working together for
the last 25 years I argue that Ken is
one of the best sweet potato breeders in
the globe and I'd stand behind that that
argument any day he's a really good
breeder Ken started the ornamental
breeding program by Crossing green uh
regular
table stock sweet potatoes
with some lime green and some purple
sweet potatoes that came out of the gene
Bank we think from the Philippines we're
not exactly sure
he just started Crossing this out of
curiosity because he's a breeder and he
wanted to see what they produced uh
Paulie poity
Crossing and Crossing sweet potato is
very difficult I won't go into that uh
but Unleashed a lot of unique
colors Vine types Leaf shapes that being
in a Horticultural science department uh
we passed these by some of her
colleagues and they said oh these are
beautiful they have ornamental potential
I have a little bit of a business
perspective in me we brought in a bunch
of major companies to kind of look at
these they got really excited about them
and our initial little
weekend the night sort of breeding kind
of a job that probably really can drove
and I kind of helped enhance it with
some contacts and and some business
ideas grew into a full-fledged
ornamental breeding program
and now we're sponsored by proven
winners uh and they support our research
up front for the ornamental side and on
the back side what they get is the is
the global rights exclusive rights to
Market our ornamental sweet potatoes
uh our ornamental sweet potatoes this is
a picture of one of our Fields a couple
years ago we now probably have about
five acres of ornamental sweet potatoes
uh that we walk and and Market each each
and and kind of walk with Proven Winners
team uh to make our our next selections
and I can tell you that the team really
enjoys that because we're exercising if
you will different breeding muscles as
we're walking these plots we're not
digging the potatoes like I do for my
other two you know for potato and sweet
potato which is hard work and that's fun
too but we're looking for beauty we're
looking for Vine color we're looking for
Vine shape we're looking for Vine you
know Leaf shape Etc uh and marking that
is is a totally different Endeavor uh
but it's led to this over the years
uh we've got 18 actively marketed
varieties now uh last count they were in
11 different countries we usually sell
several you know five plus million units
a year uh and this is the palette I
can't don't know how well you can see
that you can see it fairly well here I
guess the palette of lines that we're
looking at right now and Walter's right
as I was walking down through the
commons this Sweet Caroline B which
green is a pot plant there and you're
also going to see this other one up up
here these two here all in the mixed
Planters all around town and it's really
really fun to see that
this work has actually enhanced my table
stock work because it's bring more
resources to the table but actually the
original reference genome for sweet
potato the first reference genome that
was created I'll talk about that in just
a little bit actually came out of our
ornamental breeding efforts would have
never have guessed but we had a wild
relative that we were working on that
was sufficiently homozygous that we
could use as our original reference
genome so that was an unplanned
uh unplanned scientific output of these
colorful varieties that we're we're
still continuing to develop we've done
about 30 but we're actively marketing
about 18 right now
okay I want to touch base on potato a
little bit and I want to continue on
this polyploidy theme
you remember this picture Walter you've
seen this a lot I think uh what do you
get
when you cross a white and a purple
potato
you get this
you get all colors in the Spectrum out
of that one cross between a white
and a purple
tetraploid do tetraploids now uh and you
get this segregation at the F1 level all
right that's phenomenal recombination
for us uh and variability that comes out
of just that one cross
but the trick is
think about the
the opportunities in a cross like this
functional food products ion
anthocyanins some carotenoids phenolics
lower glycemic index because of the
starch makeup might be there
new flavors
exciting colors
different sugar starch and texture
profiles all in this segregating progeny
right lower acrylamide levels potential
anti-cancer effects right
the trick for me is or the challenge is
how do you decide what to develop and
how do you get there
partly the CG partners that we have
right now have this thing called a
product profile
all right some of us have mixed emotions
about that that that concept but in this
case the concept is probably pretty
important because you have so many
things that you can go for how do you
choose what you're going to go for and
what's the relative value and why all
right so this is one of the dilemmas
that I have as a breeder in my two crops
is we generate in one cross at the F1
level really significant variability and
every cross that we make generates that
variability again and again and again
and again but if I want to develop a
specific product profile what tools do I
use to go into that genre that I need to
in my potato breeding program
we have Specialties that are coming out
here but they're they're low market
value they they they they they won't
make a big hit but if we can develop a
new chipping variety
with good yield high specific gravity
resistance internal heat necrosis uh and
has a good size profile that's going to
go someplace so that's the challenge
here all right
now the last slide in this sort of Step
or this set of thoughts if you will is
going to be this right here and I have
it for sweet potato and then I have and
potato question mark but these are our
breeding objectives for sweet potato
reading uh and the thing that jumps out
at me really quick here is oh boy that's
a long list
to put together in one cross
right to have all of those traits line
up uh in one cross is really almost
impossible
okay so you work at building parents up
that kick out favorable progeny that
have the right attributes but generally
for us in potato and sweet potato we
have a whole long line of traits that
need to line up just right to make it
the next new big variety
now there are a lot of things in here
that are kind of minor right uh but
there's a lot of things in here that are
that are really major uh you know for
example drought heat flood tolerance is
becoming more important
I've never met a grower who doesn't
value yield all right yield is always
King
I've never met a a processor who isn't
more focused on the chemistries uh for
potato it's all about gravity and a
couple other things uh
and uh you know most consumers are
interested in the flavor characteristics
so it depends on what your product
profile looks like that you're going to
go for and some of these are going to be
really important we have the disease and
insect resistances fusarium resistance
is a must-have for us root not nematode
resistance is is a must-have now uh and
the the terrible thing about this here
is any one of these traits you could
have an otherwise really really good
variety but any one of these traits
maybe not anyone but a good proportion
of these traits
for example
flavor
might fail
in that one you might have an otherwise
really good variety but if it doesn't
have the right flavor characteristic it
might totally fail
or in storage as you start to ramp up
your quantities you pick up that you
actually are susceptible to fusarium
it'll knock the Clone out of
consideration
uh so these are the things that we
wrestle with as potato breeders and
sweet potato breeders and when we're
developing new varieties we have to put
all of these things together uh that
pick it from that variability and and
hope that we can combine a good portion
of these into into one package to make
our next new variety
all right
okay the other thing I want to touch
back based on that I've really learned a
lot from and I've really really really
enjoyed is transdisciplinary team-based
research is is required for for success
and and here I'm gonna I'm gonna kind of
reach into uh a project that I had the
pleasure of working on and then one that
I managed this is the sweet potato
action for security and and and uh
and and health in Africa Sasha
uh and it was funded by The Gates
Foundation managed by the international
data center
uh I managed a project called the gt4sp
project genomic tools for Sweepstake
Improvement project for five years with
the foundation and then these two
projects got
sort of morphed into a new project
called sweet gains gain stands for
genetic advances and Innovative seed
systems that would be the gains part and
now we've recently been all combined
together all the rtb crops into a rtb
breeding program Roots rtb stands for
roots tubers and bananas
um but I spent a lot of time building
teams for marker assisted genomic
assisted breeding and sweet potato under
the gt4sp project and the sweet gains
project and I want to tell you about
that just a little bit and actually the
story starts here
so as part of of our of our work and
trying to build
genomic assisted breeding platforms for
sweet potato we realized that one of the
things that we really needed was to put
together a team of scientists with
relative relevant expertise
across the disciplinary disciplines of
you know genome genome development all
right
bioinformatics uh we didn't at that time
have a good genotyping platform for
sweet potatoes so we kind of had to
build that uh we knew that as you're
putting all these components here
together uh you need a database platform
uh so we we reached out to Lucas and his
team to build a database platform our
analytics became very very complex so we
developed an analytical team both on a
database side in the statistical side
and then we have the Breeders at the
bottom of the pyramid making populations
and and working with the rest of the
team up above and so what I really
learned from that is the importance uh
of a team in helping the whole project
achieve its goals in my experience and
I'm not saying there might be a few of
you here at NC at Cornell that are doing
this fairly well there's very few people
that can have their feet in the ground
walk behind a tractor make selections
and could go home in the afternoon and
do all the bioinformatics
or you know take a a SQL file down and
and you know just kind of parse it and
pull out your Snips uh the engineers
that we're working with nowadays uh in
terms of optical engineering uh are just
just phenomenal so it's all about
finding a good team that works together
that is uh is good at sort of sharing
knowledge and they can see the big
picture while focusing on the important
details I was very fortunate to find a
number of people some here with Angel
Faye Lucas Sean I think are in the room
with us right now uh to help us develop
uh both both our reference you know for
sweet potato uh first reference Journal
was based on I'll go over here
then maybe I'll come back was was based
on ipamiatrifida a wild relative diploid
wild relative a sweet potato like I say
before it was actually an outcome of a
breeding project for our ornamental
breeding program that just happened to
come up at the at the right time uh we
have gone through the trifida phase high
quality very high quality reference
genome for trifida we now have moved on
to the hexaploid uh
genomes over here and zhangjun and Sean
have pretty much driven that effort we
we now have three complete genomes I
think Tanzania Beauregard new kawogo but
it's all built on trifida and our
knowledge as it expanded what we we
couldn't do the hexaploid reference
genome 10 years ago but we can now and
that really set the stage for I'll go
back
marker development
all right so we had a bioinformatics
team here uh that helped us set the
stage now we can order our markers we
know where they are we can develop
markers fairly quickly uh this helps us
a lot in the breeding population
uh we have assembled this is the
Tanzania and the new cologre this is the
Beauregard Tanzania nukuwogo next just
some of the assembly statistics that we
have for that so these are high quality
reference films at this point and with
the help of of Robin Buell who started
out this project at Michigan State moved
down to uh to uh University of Georgia
uh with 13 we now have a genomics
resource it has become a global resource
for the sweet potato breeding Community
uh that's been very very helpful over
the years
all right so that has been a really big
sea change for me in in terms of putting
a team together that they understand
their role uh in in variety development
I think that Sean and I talked yesterday
a little bit and she says she really
likes to work with reading programs just
because it serves a Connecting Point and
it gives you relevance you know you're
actually impacting society and I think a
lot of students in the room here
probably connect with that too I could
provide that Connecting Point as the
breeder of this walking up and down the
fields but we need to access those tools
to be successful
okay here's the other thing that I
wanted to visit with you about uh and
that is the thing uh is change is
constant and Mike I visited with you
just a little bit about this in my own
breeding programs uh we have to be
prepared to change
we've changed our breeding program I'd
say fairly substantially to try and
better use our genomics better use just
single Gene markers in our breeding
program how do we Implement genomic
selection in our breeding program at
what stage in our program in a cleanly
propagated crop can we again can we
begin to collect good data good
phenotypic data uh that's really
important if you're going to embark on a
genomic selection exercise because the
quality of your predictions is directly
correlated to the quality of your
phenotypic of your phenotyping abilities
and so we have wrestled with that over
the years I won't go into a lot of
detail but what you will see here is one
we used to work with several polycross
breeding nurseries before we used to
work with really large populations we'd
go out with 60 000 single plants a year
and Whittle that population down very
quickly over the next three or four
years uh these first two years because
of the size of our breeding plots we
didn't collect a lot of good data on
them
most it was just making a selection and
taking notes so we weren't collecting
good data
so we realized the value of that and we
gradually changed our our breeding
structure we've gone from polycross
nurseries to almost all paired cross
nurseries we no longer can do 60 000
seedlings we're happy to do 25
000 seedlings we've realized that uh in
this cycle one because we were getting
basically no data that if we went to
three plant plots at cycle one uh that
would prepare us with a larger planting
population for year two uh where we
could start getting accurate data we
could start phenotyping uh better our
materials and we can handle that and now
we can start genotyping in year two and
pump those data on our G on our year two
year three and year four data that we're
Gathering back into our models and
that's kind of what has happened with
the sweet potato breeding program from
that point of view so we have changed
the flow of our materials through the
program and we've really recognized the
value of good data collection we'll
touch base on that and a little bit more
on on that so that's been that's been
certainly consistent through my sweet
potato program
same thing uh with my potato breeding
program
now Walter asked me the other day what
comes first the potato or sweet potato
in terms of innovation
all right and my answer back was it
depends uh so our multiple plant plots
was actually modeled on Cornell's
breeding program uh so multiple plants
started in my potato breeding program
long before it started in sweet potato
so we've we've kind of you go back and
forth both both crops feed each other
this is what we used to do uh on my
potato program we would go out with
about 15 000 lines single plants uh and
you would take a couple years to get up
to the larger plot size most of the
decisions are made on appearance at this
point here not a lot of data taken but a
lot of a lot of appearance a lot of sort
of seat of the pants which is valuable
don't get me wrong uh but it doesn't
provide you enough numbers to make
rational decisions and then you know the
data is where we got here
we've changed now uh now we're doing
less than ten thousand uh seedlings but
we're doing five plant plots all right
that five plant plot here allows us to
jump up quite a bit in year two uh that
we're collecting our DNA from from this
section on here and we're going out with
multiple unreplicated trials in three
different sites eight Planet plots and
we phenotype the whole population
all right and so that has changed quite
a quite a bit now there's two things
that I'd like to point out to you here
real quick and if you can see it from
here uh that's a little bit simple
more complex
sweet potato same thing we didn't make
the job easier ourselves we made it more
complex there's no doubt about that in
my mind we made a job a little bit
harder but I think the output that we're
getting is is better so in some cases it
gets a little bit simpler but in many
cases it got a little bit more complex
for us all right
uh this is the other thing that I that
I'll point out here that I've learned
that's really important and again this
doesn't apply to all breeding program it
doesn't necessarily apply to my
ornamental breeding program
all right but my other programs which
are a little bit different uh this
applies uh what I've learned is
operational excellence is really really
critical to Our Success if we can't get
the DNA collection done right if we
can't get the DNA timing sent off
properly all those little operational
aspects of the breeding program if we
can't get those right then we're we're
not going to be doing a good job or
it'll be sub-optimal so I've really
learned the value of having sop standard
operating procedures good operational uh
procedures in your program and a good
flow of materials all right
back to teamwork
no one person can take care of all of
that right so you're you're relying on
your genomics group your your genotyping
crew
you can get the DNA to them they can get
it dry they can get Center Intertech
they go over to Dart tag and get back in
less than a month
all right doing that is is a big thing
doing that on the continent of Africa
gets even more complex all right so
those operational things uh DNA
extraction genotyping and bioinformatics
phenotyping and analytics all really
important and we're all relying on the
team members to help us achieve that
goal
okay let's finish up here with uh big
data and complex analytics and I'll
spend a little bit of time on this I
think
uh
first of all uh we're breeders
and so we've made a lot of really good
mapping populations this is one of our
our Marquee mapping populations it's the
Beauregard by Tanzania mapping
population I think I have a slide
showing this in just a sec but all of
this is to show you that being able to
make sense
out of two complex hexaploids that are
crossed at the F1 level is not an easy
task
uh we're using modified forms of GBS uh
just like you all are here right now for
our Snips and we we've got high density
snip maps of of sweet potato that that
can map all 90 linkage groups right and
we can pair the homologs together so we
we know everybody that's that's pairing
together and and that's worked out quite
well we've done a lot of q-tail mapping
in in the BT population we've identified
qtl for beta-carotene dry matter starch
glucose fructose sucrose and more I'll
touch base on that a little bit more
uh We've developed another population so
we cut our teeth on this one this is the
size of the population right here with
the original qtl mapping exercise
we do read the maze literature by the
way
and we developed our own form of a nam
population
this isn't like the Nam population
exactly but this is what we call the
Moana diversity panel which is an eight
by eight dialogue population 20 sibs
about 1520 or so size population uh
these are the this is developed by uh Dr
Robert mwanga and Bernard yada at the
international potato Center and uh the
knockri the narrow National agricultural
research organization in Uganda using
mostly African land races and released
varieties uh in a large diversity panel
this has now been phenotyped on many
occasions we're just concluding we hope
the genotyping work on that and the the
work that the team is going to do on
this in terms of tracking traits through
these materials but also developing uh
I'd say genetic based genomic selection
strategies based on inheritance and
pedigree I'm really looking forward to
seeing what our team comes through for
that because this population is going to
be sort of the Forerunner of a lot of
the analytical uh genetic mapping work
that the team is going to be engaged on
that's being led by this gang right here
primarily Xiao bang and Marcelo and then
Hillary de Silva who's at the University
of yokosa down in Brazil is uh is a lot
of the uh the new uh g-was and qtl
mapping strategies that we're engaged in
all right
uh we have identified qtl for
beta-carotene and a number of loci that
associated with beta-carotene production
I was joking around with Bob and and uh
and Doctor placed it and uh and Walter
uh in potato the hot the hot linkage
group is
uh Lucas you know the hot linkers group
in potato right
chromosome 5.
is a big is a big deal in potato it
seems like all the good loci map there
for some reason I don't know why
chromosome 3 is is sweet potato right
here uh and right there it is is a major
Gene for beta-carotene all right that
happens to be linked with starch
accumulation so they're a negative
linkage ah the cassava folks know this
already don't they and we have broken
that one so there don't work you're good
yeah we got hydrometer orange flushers
Rebecca's saying finally finally
uh so we've done a lot of work in in
this area
uh this is before this is the Tanzania
by Beauregard cross uh Tanzania is a is
an African land race uh does not produce
any Roots at all in North Carolina's
environment but as a major land race in
East Africa Beauregard so white fleshed
high dry matter Beauregard major Variety
in the U.S orange flesh Low Dry matter
uh they combine nicely and we've done a
lot of work on that and this just kind
of gives you a look at what segregation
looks like in in that cross right there
okay so you get a lot of interesting uh
genotypes out of that
uh it turns out the Tanzania for my own
breeding program and this goes back to a
question that that The Graduate students
had for me is how do I integrate my
reading program my International aspects
of my breeding program how do I sell
that to my domestic commodity groups
because there's attention there
occasionally it turns out that Tanzania
has great resistance to every nematode
we've tossed at it and we have two new
nematodes that have recently come into
North Carolina one and old one
malignagani incognita uh Southern uh
nematode and a new one uh malidigani in
uh interlobi a guava root not nematode
quarantine pests causing lots of
problems for us
turns out that from Tanzania
we've got high levels of resistance to
Southern root not the litigani incognita
single Gene single dominant gene this is
what we all wish for in our crops right
even better this is for southern
on linkage group seven
uh and then we have another one
uh on linkage group four for uh
malidigani enterlobei uh guava root not
nematology again single Gene dominant
high levels of resistance
both derived from Tanzania
why they're there I have no idea
but it we have now been doing a lot of
Crossing uh let me go back using this in
our breeding program to intergress those
genes into our breeding materials and
move them through the pipeline very very
fast to do that because we now have a
great team on board
uh we have been able to create cast
markers because we have a reference
genome now uh because we can work with
Intertech on that and LGC biosciences we
now have cast markers that are fairly
good at predicting resistance that we
can use as markers we're confirming
those in other breeding populations so
far it seems like it's holding up but
I'm I'm kind of cautious here still and
so we're beginning to use these markers
in our breeding program to facilitate
our our root not nematode resistance
work this by the way is what Tanzania
looks like in North Carolina
it's not very pretty yeah and the guy
holding that is well he's not very
pretty either
all right
uh so these are the cast markers that
we've now developed uh in sweet potato
we have one for flesh color uh dry
matter skin color firmness and two for
uh interlobi we are validating all of
these right now all right but these
would be the first use of marker
assisted breeding in sweet potato in
addition to our genomic work
the other thing that we've learned a lot
uh in our complex polyploids is that
dosage matters
it's one thing to model a trait using a
diploid model but really especially in
sweet potato even more so than potato
dosage matters so when we have a snip we
need sufficient depth sequencing depth
to model that stems dosage in addition
or if we make it into a haplotype-based
version we need to model that also so
all of our algorithms right now are
predicated on that fact
in general
it's more important for some traits than
other traits but in general doses
matters and if we can get it we will
take it because it will enhance our
predictability it might enhance our
predictability by only 0.1 or 0.2 but
when you're down in the realm of 0.3 to
0.5 and you could bump it up to 0.4.6
hey you'll take it it helps me make
better predictions so that's a big deal
that that we have learned throughout the
course of the work and again I go back
to that team concept I don't have the
skill set to do that
but our analytical team does
and I can ask the question and say oh I
think this is important we can model
that and that's the value of the
teamwork that I have experienced
uh I this is our genomic prediction
models here so far uh they have done
well uh some of our predictions like the
I think it was the the the h block uh
generally has given us better
predictions across a range of traits uh
than than other formats but this is an
area that I think is is still really
really uh we have a lot a lot of work
yet to do uh in in sweet potato to
realize this and also in potato and one
of the things that that is uh well I'm
gonna I'm gonna pop here and I'm gonna
go I think let me see here yeah I'm
gonna pop here the other thing that that
I've learned that is really really
important is when you're when you're
Gathering lots of data both phenotypic
data and genotypic data you better have
a good database
and so fortunately we've been working
with Lucas Mueller's team at bti I know
many of you are familiar with the breed
base Enterprise uh I think we were the
second base after cassava base I think
that's right all right but it now is
five or six different other crops here
now uh we have at least four breeding
platforms that are actively using uh we
call it sweet potato base all right uh
across the continent in in uh in Africa
and certainly my program here uh uses it
you know pretty much a daily and this
time of year they're going out to the
field and getting Harvest and they're
they're they're downloading their their
clones and accessions using breed base
uh on the fly in many cases and and
using that as what we're doing for the
day we use it to construct our trials uh
we tried a round trip as best we can
what we have found is that we need
somebody with I.T experience uh luckily
Lucas has provided those over the years
for us uh that we can reach into them
and and and kind of help them kind of
work out all the bugs that will turn up
and stuff like this but it's been a big
deal
uh going back to genomic selection
uh this is one of the biggest things
that I am wrestling with personally and
I don't think we'll solve that problem
here I'm just trying to be cognizant of
time uh
key issue that I'm wrestling with is
going back to what I said earlier a lot
of traits have to align just right uh
you know to make a new variety and we're
all about varieties here right we want
to build up our breeding populations
make new varieties but a lot of traits
have to align uh and I can't model all
those traits
but I can maybe will it down to maybe
four to six and which four to six are
the most important ones are going to
depend on individual breeding programs
but those are going to be four to six
traits that have to deal with field
performance
much of My Success is actually based on
culinary performance so I've got a dozen
more traits that I need to model
for flavor or for sugar or for Browning
uh and how do I kind of Juggle those two
together we're still on that learning
path right now and maybe we'll talk
about it later on in a couple sidebar
conversations how to kind of wrestle
with that I'm still sort of struggling
with that how do I how do I manage that
in my breeding program in the context of
that
one last thing that I'll share with you
has really been fun and I think it's a
game changer for us if I can if we can
get it right is using and I think this
can translate to into the African
context quite well too is using optical
Imaging machine deep learning artificial
intelligence now to uh to model yield or
to predict yield from Storage routes
data in the field
uh we have started out quite a bit uh
just using plot level these are plot
level images taken with our
cell phone actually taken with field
book because field book labels all of
our images with the barcoded and it tags
it and we know what where the plot came
from and we have all the all the
metadata right there embedded in the
code uh our first thing was is to mask
the sweet potatoes
and then we asked our Optical
engineerings and our computer scientist
colleagues I want to know the weight of
each one of those sweet potatoes I want
to know the count
of the sweet potatoes in that plot I
want to know the weight I want to know
the length I want to know the diameter I
want to know the LD
because those five traits are really
critical for us in terms of selecting so
we worked with a guy by name of Mike
kudenoff and kranos uh Williams uh in
our department of computer and science
engineering we started off on this
journey right here
we pretty much can show that we could do
that this one's a little bit messy
our next iteration was flying with
drones
so now we fly it with a UAV these are
are you can you can see here these plots
are nice and ordered right they're kind
of easier these are dug with a sweet
potato Digger with it with a two row
chain Digger and then we just fly it
over slowly with the Drone uh and then
we apply the algorithm that was
developed earlier to mask these storage
routes and you can see it's doing a
fairly good job soil type makes a
difference you can see on cloudy soil
right here might be a little bit harder
but it actually does a pretty good job
and so now the trick is is converting
these images into counts per plot uh
weights of individual sweet potatoes
sizes of those sweet potatoes and and
using that
uh we're getting a little bit further
along here now uh this is actually
another test that we've been doing
where we flew the field with a drone
these are actually bedded plots they're
going to be used for seed
but we're testing our hypothesis out
that we can do this in the field
this is one of my graduate students who
just finished his uh
master's degree just left for UC Davis
to do his PhD he's brilliant uh flew the
field with a drone uh individual plot
right here we can mask all that we can
segment that plot
using this algorithm here and identify
individual plots in the field and then
this down here it's hard to see but this
is the individual data coming from those
and those you might ask how accurate are
they
this is our prediction for root weight
individual root weight we had some data
that was that was entered in wrong when
they were taking the physical data right
we parse those out you can see that
we've got an R square estimated weight
versus predicted weight which is
actually doggone fine from from that
work there
uh and then I think let's see here
yeah there's just this other one here
this is a storage root yield and shape
uh so again root counts here let me go
back it's this is a yeah data removed
there and then root counts on here so
we're actually coming along pretty far
in this one and this year we're actually
putting a camera on the back of our of
our digger uh and it's actually
measuring yield real time come across
the Digger we were trying to do that
we're going to see if we can do that
going back to what I said here is where
do we change the breeding program
now we have to think about well how do
we change our breeding program so we can
get this data and I'm pretty much
convinced because my gang is not going
to wait for you to fly the Drone and
then walk the plots
we just can't wait like that right
so my hunch is actually the data that we
leave behind is just as important if not
more important than the data We Gather
so now we're sort of thinking backwards
is we want to know what we drop we're
going to fly the whole field we're going
to look at all of the population and
we're going to enhance our
predictability by looking at what we
keep but also what we don't keep and
these new tools kind of allow us to kind
of start to ask those questions I'll
finish up here now yeah
ah okay
so I think as I as I wrap up this thing
here this little little figure here sort
of you know encapsulates some of my
thoughts here we've done a good job of
training people we've got next
Generation breeders on the ground
starting to do really good work we have
a lot more work to do here that's partly
you know why why we're here got a good
reference genome we've got great
genotyping methods now well we've got
better genotyping methods I think we
need to work on that uh we've got
phenomenal polyploid mapping and qtl
Analysis strategies that are down to
pipe as a result of several projects
all across the globe we've got some
really good reading populations being
developed uh and we've got robust
database and electronic data capture we
pretty much capture all of our data
using you know fieldable cap
pretty much all of this done that way uh
and and that's that's been really good
so I think we got the tools in place but
it's the team it's all about the team
that helps you know kind of Drive things
forward
and with that uh I'm just going to say
this
is just a quick recap for us polyploid
is an almost endless source of
variability uh but harnessing it is
easier said than done all right
uh translator team-based research is
required uh for success but teams can be
hard to manage but when they function
well or it doesn't get any better it is
really great to see people doing great
things
change is a constant uh be prepared to
continually change your breeding program
and to grow all right uh and this last
one here is is Big Data and complex
analysts are here to stay I think I'm
fairly secure in that statement uh boy
but I need a better handle put on that
toolkit for me to manage so that would
be my ask for the data folks here is
give me a better give me a better handle
for my toolkit it's a great toolkit I
just need a better handle on it
uh and the last thing that I'll say is
it's really really really an exciting
time to be a breeder you've got a lot of
challenges ahead of you students uh but
you have you've got tools like you've
never had before and you've got great
challenges and and uh I I'm looking
forward to seeing what you do
and I'll stop there I'll thank some of
our partners uh on the sweet potato side
and some of our partners on the potato
side and they kind of all make it happen
so I I I I forgive me if I've gone on
just a little bit too long
please ask at least one question because
if you don't get a question then yeah go
ahead
no no
there's not right now uh but you know I
I one of my my responses is is that one
what do you get when you when you reduce
a hexaploid sweet potato
you got a triplet I mean so I I think
that that that aspiration is more
logically put in potato and I can see
that but I don't see that coming in
sweet potato and I could go on for about
the breeding systems and
incompatibilities Etc much more
difficult than sweet potato than potato
yeah good question though yeah
saw somebody else around here
yeah there you go I was also asking
thinking about the whole diploid
question I mean but but the powerful
tools you now have
you know you can drive GS fast enough
and everything else do you really care
if you had a you know even if you could
make a a diploid would you want to do it
I honestly I I can't answer that
question and I think that some potato
breeders are asking that same question
too to be honest with you yeah I'm
looking at it from both you know for me
I'ma never put your eggs in one basket
kind of guy right I'm gonna spread your
risk uh I'm on the anxiously waiting to
see what happens on the diploid breeding
side excited about it uh and I've
offered ourselves as a phenotyping
station
I don't have the resources to engage in
that on the potato side but I'm
anxiously looking for some others to
send me clones and see how they perform
yeah Gene editing is is another thing
you know we have new Tools in gene
editing if we can overcome some other
barriers that are going to be used to
enhance crop performance I think that's
a big deal too but that's that's a
10-year Horizon for me at least
yeah and I don't plan on being around
that long yeah go ahead
Keenan did I see a Hannah over here no
well
you know you're gonna ask the hard
question aren't you yeah
the potatoes plant the billion seedlings
find the 50 000.
I haven't figured that out yet but but I
do know that for say uh in my own
breeding program for uh root not
nematode it's become a really important
trait and it's really really hard to
bioaf say for so all of our parents are
now going to have to have that marker uh
and we'll use that on the potato side we
talked about it for the single Gene
traits all of our parents are are now
having pvy either adg or still and and
will enhance our currents for those
values those other markers
we'll see where they come in due course
my colleagues in Africa might have a
different value proposition and they'll
use them differently it's still too
expensive uh to do on all of your single
on all of your your first cycle
selections we just tossed away too many
so it's kind of wasted money unless
you're unless you're focusing on parents
but we'll use them in our seconds in our
third years because it's cost efficient
for us I mean we can do them for less
than 10 bucks a pop and we could do them
in-house too if we want to but it's
easier for us to send them out to to
InterTech yeah Rebecca thanks so much
um good seeing you by the way
and good to see all these fantastic
progress um
so you mentioned the importance of
operational
definitely the part of the handle of the
toolkit that you're looking after a few
years ago in this in this room Steve
Kingsley made I think kind of a splash
with us talking about how the math of
operations thinking
could be applied or how is being applied
with you know pretty good style in in
some reading programs you know at work
and some of his thinking I'm wondering
is is that school's not pertinent to
what you've been talking about or
shouldn't be I I think it is pertinent I
remember Steve giving a talk at pag
along those same lines and I was
somewhat fascinated by it too uh and in
fact we tried to recruit him as an
advisor for one of our programs uh but
he didn't have time
I I think it's I think it is uh it's
relevant I don't know that I put pencil
to paper if you will uh to sort of look
at that point of views but we have
fought long and hard about like what
point in the breeding cycle does it make
sense and what can we reasonably manage
at that point uh given the resources
that we have uh we kind of do it that
way I I should say that I we have
embarked on an exercise uh I actually on
the potato side where we're starting to
quantify all aspects of our breeding
program just out of curiosity actually
it's in response to a breeding partner
that wants to work with us and we want
to come up with realistic numbers so
we're starting to kind of do that to
kind of put it like you know how
expensive is it for our second years you
know what does that look like in terms
of Human Resources in Manpower so we're
starting that and that might be a start
for that you start to look at it it's
damn expensive to run a large-scale
breeding program yeah
John Luke
um you had that slide with three or four
columns
full of traits that all mattered yeah
and uh I won't go all the way back there
so so I'm curious do you try to estimate
an economic value for each of these
traits Ah that's a really good point
yeah right I mean in animal breeding
they have at least 80 dairy cow breeding
80 trades that they pay attention to one
way or another so it's
it seems to me the number of traits
isn't isn't a killer is is this question
of do you believe that you have economic
values that are meaningful yeah and
that's a stellar question actually yeah
yeah
oh uh here's the way I think about that
and and it it might be totally
irrational
um we sort of we sort of know what
traits are the most value that that uh
based on our interactions with Growers
and processors which are fairly
substantial
uh we sort of know which ones they value
the most and which ones will sync or or
rise a new clone to the top of the list
but parents I mean I understand a new
variety it has to some thresholds or
something but your parents parents don't
right no but you're you're right about
that but but we will we will actively
work to have high quality parents with
with those high quality traits the
interesting thing is that that doesn't
the best parents aren't always the ones
with the best combination of traits
would you agree with that statement
you'd be surprised at some of the dogs
that give you some really good stuff uh
and you learn that through successive
Crossing and measuring their breeding
value maybe measuring like I suggested
what we leave on the ground is just as
important as what we carry forward but
the thing that that struck me with your
your question there is
fusarium great example uh in potato
resistance to internal heat necrosis
really it's it's a it's a high value
trait but it's only expressed uh you
know in the South sometimes and under
high stress environments heat and
drought kind of Bring It On
um it's something that we can't measure
real well uh
but yet that one trait
can disqualify an entire variety
that variety might be have great yield
great gravity fry bright white uh but in
the south of it expresses heat necrosis
one or two years out of five
you're done and it's tough to put a
price on that but that's the penalty you
pay and there are those those traits
that kind of sneak up on you as you
scale to Tractor Trailer Load sizes to
those sizes that we as breeders can't
really we can model that really well but
we can't really predict it what's going
to happen at that scale as you scale up
and that's been the that's been the you
know that's brought us to close to tears
in more than one occasion yeah so those
things kind of come up I hear what
you're saying uh that that's that would
be good but there are all those other
little things that sort of come up scab
you know a big one if you hit a scabby
field or so yeah
yes
so how long does it take to do this
again
compared to them
I can't answer that question because we
haven't done that just yet I'm hoping if
I can reduce the breeding the the time
to release a new variety by maybe two
years I think that would be reasonable
we're looking at uh in sweet potato
usually a another if you're super fast a
six to eight year time Horizon uh potato
eight to twelve
it is and and with a little bit of luck
so potato a little bit longer just
because of the seed propagation part the
scaling up part sweet potato we can
scale so much faster uh our vegetative
indexes is so much quicker we can we can
we can bulk up really fast we can get
ahead of things
um on potato a little bit longer so if
we can knock two years off that cycle if
we can knock three years off that cycle
I think we'll be doing good uh but I
think we we still need to test that and
where I really see the genomic selection
working for us is you don't look like
you're saying
parents building better parents that
kick out much favor much more favorable
progeny at a much higher frequency uh
that are that that have better Suite of
traits that are sort of
built together yeah
yeah
ah good question no uh but we for both
crops we have extensive uh I'll take off
the extensive we have on-farm trials uh
both potato and sweet potato we're we're
three to five on Farm trials a year and
generally uh those are done very close
uh with the grower the grower will walk
the fields with us we're using all the
Growers equipment uh in a sweet potato
we're using the the uh both the his or
her planting equipment and we're also
using their their labor which is it
which is which is a big deal uh and it
it has been a really uh valuable part of
our breeding program in terms of keeping
us connected I think in terms of
understanding Growers perspectives wants
and needs but I think it's a two-way
process in that the Growers sort of look
at it through breeding eyes too and they
get a they get an idea on scale you know
what does it take you know how how to
manage it that's that's been really good
so we're we're out there every year we
we have on-farm trials generally with
the progressive Growers too they're
they're usually the ones that invite you
on and they're they're interested in
doing things and learning things from
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu